et bonjour laurent pietra chaise qui
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
secrétaire d'état chargé des retraites
et de la santé au travail en étant
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale et christelle
bertrand on va nous rejoindre on dirait
christelle bertrand bonjour allez-y je
vous en prie installez-vous christelle
juste à côté de moi christelle qui
représente ici le groupe la dépêche
merci beaucoup pour être avec me
christelle mon genre laurent pillet
trajet ce qui on va commencer par une
question simple mais une réponse que
tout le monde attend il y aura t-il ou
non une réforme des retraites avant la
fin du quinquennat deux minutes pour la
réponse quand même
mais on veut quand même réponse claire
je suis entend bien j'entends bien et
ont coûté le prix dont la république a
été clair c'est pour ça que sur le fond
vous allez retrouver dans mes propos ce
que le président de république a dit le
12 juillet qu'at-il dit le 12 juillet
elle a dit que nous avons aujourd'hui
une situation sanitaire qui est sérieuse
et elle est toujours on a à près de dix
mille de nos concitoyens qui sont
hospitalisés pour des raisons qu vide et
près de 2000 qui sont en réanimation il
a dit li a aussi la nécessité d'ancrer
cette relance économique et et c'est
vrai que les chiffres sont bons l'action
du gouvernement là il récompensera on
voit bien d'avoir maintenu les
entreprises avec la tête hors de l'eau
pendant cette crise sanitaire et d'avoir
préservé les emplois tout cela est
positif avec un taux de croissance qui
devrait être supérieur à 6% pour 2021
c'est plein de critères nous faut
ces critères vous venez de dire vous
même ce sont des prévisions de
croissance et ce qu'il faut maintenant
c'est ancré les choses pourquoi qu'est
ce que nous voyons le chômage certes est
revenue à son niveau d'avant 2019 mais
nous voulons que les jeunes notamment et
nous voyons que le chômage de longue
durée et le chômage des seniors
progress il nous faut être
particulièrement attentifs à cette
situation économique et sociale et
sanitaire pour l'instant le gouvernement
est mobilisé sur ces deux sujets le
sanitaire et l'économique et sociale
viendra le temps 6 à votre question
viendra le temps de faire cette réforme
lorsque nous serons en situation à la
fois au niveau sanitaire au niveau
économique et social ce risque on
comprend pas bien c'est quels sont les
critères on l'a dit les prévisions
économiques de croissance à son bonne
l'économie repart n'y a pas eu d'effet
de la quatrième vague sur l'économie et
la situation sanitaire elle semble en
voie d'amélioration en tout cas en ce
qui concerne la quatrième as que
précisément vous avez des critères est
ce que c'est un nombre de patients
hospitalisés est ce que ça est-ce que
c'est quand tu auras plus de variants
quels sont les critères précisément et
que vous laissez pas à table aux
mathématiques ça marche pas c'est pas un
modèle mathématique qui déclenche
l'action politique l'action politique
elle se déclenche au au regard à la fois
de la situation de la société de notre
niveau de disponibilité globale giresse
d'acceptation aussi de transformation de
notre société ma conviction en moins
c'est qu'il faut faire cette réforme des
retraites la question c'est quand la
question c'est quand parce que
effectivement il faut que nous soyons
tous collectivement près à cette
transformation si nous voulons avoir une
protection sociale de qualité comme nous
avons aujourd'hui nous avons les niveaux
de pensions des plus élevés des pays
industrialisés nous avons et c'est tant
mieux une espérance de vie à la retraite
de plus de 26 ans parmi les plus élevés
des pays industrialisés il nous faut
financer tout cela il nous faut le faire
et moi je le crois je vous le dis en
travaillant alors gabriela talent le
porte-parole du gouvernement a annoncé
ce week-end à la fête de l'humanité que
certaines parties de cette réforme des
retraites pourrait être mise en oeuvre
avant la fin du quinquennat est ce que
ça vous paraît possible et quelles
parties de quel parti par le tien oui je
vais pas vous faire ici une illustration
à la découpe de la transformation du
système de retraites puisqu'on a un peu
le temps disons un bon quand même de
notre système de retraite
système de retraite par répartition ce
sont les actifs ceux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui qui par leurs cotisations
paye les pensions de retraite de leurs
aînés c'est la réalité de notre système
ce système il faut qu'ils soient à
l'équilibré alors pas forcément sur une
année mais en tous les cas de façon
tendancielle qu'est ce que nous
constatons nous avons aujourd'hui un
système qui est déficitaire nous aurons
pour 2021 près de 8 milliards de déficit
la tendance estimée par le conseil
d'orientation des retraites c'est autour
d'une dizaine de milliards par an de
déficit à l'horizon 2030 donc si nous
regardons la situation sur dix années à
venir nous avons près d'une centaine de
milliards de difficiles sur ce système
de retraite donc bien sûr qu'il nous
faudra le rééquilibrer il nous faut leur
équilibre et parce que sinon nous
laissons la charge à nos plus jeunes à
la fois de payer par leurs cotisations
des pensions des aînés mais aussi nous
leur laissons la charge de la dette cds
à nu son double charge à nos plus jeunes
et moi mais servette a su en effet que
mes filles vous enfoncer les voies
transition sans réforme soit système par
répartition il est en danger aujourd'hui
mais écoutez il et menacer notre système
par répartition si nous ne prenons pas
dans le temps les bonnes décisions pour
l'équilibré et c'est ce que nous voulons
faire et c'est ce que nous ferons j'ai
compris votre question preuves mais
c'est ce que nous ferons le moment venu
lorsque à la fois la situation sanitaire
fous pourquoi entretenir ce flou
pourquoi ne pas dire clairement on sera
pas en mesure de le faire d'ici la fin
du quinquennat où il y aura des mesures
qui seront prises d'ici la fin du
quinquennat mais tout simplement il vous
a pas échappé que la situation sanitaire
était particulièrement évolutif vous est
réjoui et puis après tout on peut le
faire avec vous
du fait qu' il y a dans notre pays une
capacité à passer cette quatrième vague
et cela essentiellement grâce à la
stratégie vaccinale que le gouvernement
a déployé et pour lesquels pour lequel
les français ont répondu présent
rappelons que depuis le discours du 12
juillet du président de la république
nous sommes à plus de 11 millions de
nouvelles injections près de 50 millions
de nos concitoyens ont au moins une
injection donc nous sommes dans une
situation sanitaire évolutive nous
sommes dans une situation économique qui
reste fragile même si la tendance est
bonne et bien c'est cela que nous
voulons confirmer avant d'avancer sur
des réformes qu'ils ont structurelles on
comprend bien vous voulez pas en dire
plus sur le timing mais certains
aujourd'hui au gouvernement dit c'est
très fun et c'est resserrement global
c'est un grand tout et donc il faut
qu'on attende le prochain quinquennat si
si il y à pour la faire pour qu elle ce
qu'elle ait une cohérence d'autres
disent mon peut commencer comme gabriel
attal à avancer sur certains points
avant la fin du quinquennat quelle est
votre opinion sur ce débat là mais je
vous met à l'aise n'y a pas de débat au
sein du gouvernement sur est ce qu'il
faut faire telle partie de la retraite
ou telle autre simplement le président
du cas le 12 juillet dont il nous a
donné une feuille au manteau nizon de
porter une attention particulière
notamment sur la situation des petites
retraites et sur la nécessité d'arriver
à un système qui soit plus juste où on
n'est pas autant d'écart sur ce relais
notamment un et durée de cotisation et
l'âge de départ ce sont clairement à la
disparition des régimes spéciaux
sur la table
la fin de la situation économique était
sanitaire le permet forcément avant la
fin du quinquennat écoutez moi je suis
en difficulté pour vous répondre ainsi
que trois semaines christophe castaner
par exemple que le patron des députés de
la république en marche dimanche il
évoquait le budget de la sécurité
sociale qui sera examinée dans quelques
semaines par le parlement et disait que
pourraient figurer dans ce budget la
retraite minimum à 1000 euros est ce que
ça c'est tim piste à écouter sur les
petites retraites la volonté du
gouvernement allait total d'abord
jusqu'au dire un mot c'est bien
mon cabinet et l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui ont voté
très récemment l'augmentation du minimum
de retraite pour les exploitants
agricoles c'est près de 227 mille chefs
d'exploitations agricoles qui vont voir
leur minimum de retraite passer à 1035
euros au 1er novembre payer début
décembre ça c'est la réalité du travail
du gouvernement qui s'occupe des petites
retraites dont ce sujet les petites
retraites effectivement on ne peut pas
uniquement le regarder sur des
catégories spécifiques même si g il faut
pas oublier ce qu'on doit au monde
agricole on lui doit notamment cette
capacité à être resté au travail pendant
la crise sanitaire n'oublions pas que ce
sont celles et ceux qui nous nourrissent
et je crois que le signal que le
gouvernement et le parlement je le dis à
vous les envoyer aux exploitants
agricoles est un bon signal donc ce
sujet fait partie de notre cul
ça le moment venu
la situation sanitaire économique j'ai
bien compris la question est ce que sera
dans pardon pour le jargon b dans le
plfss
eh bien écoutez aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
prévu comme cela voilà il nous aurons
simplement à discuter nous aurons à voir
lorsque le moment sera opportun parce
qu'encore une fois je vous l'aï dit le
sujet des petites retraites il faut se
regarder aussi de façon large aux nôtres
moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille
regarder uniquement au travers du statut
et donc ça veut dire que ça pose la
question de l'universalité et donc ça
pose la question globale de cette
réforme des retraites d'accord alors
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est dans
votre région à roubaix en précisément
pour annoncer les conclusions du bureau
de la sécurité
la région c'est aussi celle de xavier
bertrand est ce qu'il est déjà en
campagne
face à xavier bertrand le président
aujourd'hui bah c'est surtout la région
de plusieurs millions de citoyens qui
habitent les hauts de france
hossa et moi je me suis engagé en
politique en 2017 parce que je trouvais
que les politiques étaient souvent en
écart entre ce qu'il proposait ce qu'ils
arrivaient à mettre en oeuvre et moi je
me suis engagée pour transformer le
modèle social je me suis engagé et c'est
pour ça que j'ai portée quand j'étais
député la transformation du code du
travail et du dialogue social au travers
les ordonnances dites pénicaud que j'ai
accompagné la loi qui permet à chacun
maintenant de choisir son avenir
professionnel de nuit 18 et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs vous m'avez interrogé
longuement dessus ce matin que je veux
transformer notre système de retraite
pour le rendre à la fois plus juste et
plus pérenne dans le temps donc la
question de
ce que fait le président de l'exécutif
des hauts de france aujourd'hui j'ai
bien compris ma écoutez je vois que
comme d'ailleurs je l'avais dit pendant
cette campagne régionale plus de temps à
s'occuper de son projet personnel qui
est d'être le candidat de la droite
conservatrice que de s'occuper des
citoyens des hauts de france moi je le
regrette je pense qu'il devrait se
consacrer pleinement aux enjeux et des
hauts de france vous savez on sort de la
rentrée scolaire la région à la des
obligations notamment sur les lycées moi
je pense qu'il aurait été mieux venu
qu'ils travaillent sur ce sujet là
plutôt que sur sa candidature à
s'éparpiller un petit peu partout dans
les médias
choisis robert
lui on va pas si je cherchais xavier
bertrand sur ses terres sur des domaines
qui sont plus est nommé la droite le
domaine sécuritaire je crois que d'abord
le président de la république c'est la
première fois qu'ils se déplacent dans
l'autre france et il est venu à de
nombreuses reprises c'est aussi sa
région si le précisé ce matin que la
mienne ou celle du président de
l'exécutif régional
c'est sa région et je crois très
profondément qu'il aime à roubaix nous
avons la chance d'avoir l'école de
police et c'était important qu'ils
puissent venir à l'école de police pour
parler du boulot de la sécurité pour
parler de cette concentration comme très
inédite qui permettait de mettre sur la
table tous les maux que rencontrent nos
forces de l'ordre parfois les
difficultés auxquelles sont confrontés
moi je veux aussi la dire les choses
entre
2007 et 2012 presque moins dix mille
dans les effectifs des forces de l'ordre
ou c'est ce sont ceux comme le président
de l'exécutif régional des hauts de
france qui nous explique comment il faut
faire de la sécurité bien eux ils ont
réduit les effectifs et bien nous avec
gérald darmanin nous sommes à plus de
1000 nous avec gérald darmanin nous
avons changé près de la moitié du parc
de véhicules des forces de police vous
savez ces cinq milles 8 essais 3008
grise que vous voyez dans la rue siglée
police ça c'est une action concrète du
gouvernement nous avec notre action
concrète c'est aussi des actions de
pilonnages qu'outre le deal contre le
trafic de drogue ce sont des actions qui
sont en forte hausse depuis le début
d'année avec désincarcération avec des
gardes à vue avec des points de villes
qui sont des banques et ça c'est la
réalité de l'action moi je pense que le
président de la république a raison à la
fois de s'intéresser à la politique
globale de sécurité qui est mené par le
ministre de l'intérieur sous l'autorité
du premie ce parce que ça lui tient à
coeur oui aussi céline qu'ils le fassent
à roubaix un endroit où on forme nos
politiques est ce qu'on peut attendre
des annonces du président de la
république aujourd'hui vous dites y'a un
problème d'effectif est ce qu'il va
annoncer et ses effectifs
supplémentaires des revalorisations de
salaires on sait bien ce qu'attendent
les policiers aujourd'hui ce qui va
répondre à ça d'abord je vous ai dit que
grâce à nous il y avait moins de
problèmes d'effectif et je peux me
laisser jouer chez moi chez moi à
armentières à lille je vois bien les
effectifs que nous avons eu en plus
depuis 2010 est donc ça c'est une
réalité et c'est une vérité des chiffres
que je pense que c'est bien de revenir
sur les chiffres de son temps pour dire
ce qui est fait et ce qui n'a pas été
fait vous parlez de la rémunération
depuis 2010 est c'est notre gouvernement
qui a permis une évolution de plus de
100 euros par mois de la rémunération
des gardiens la paix comme dégrader et
il y a vous savez dans le quotidien o je
discute avec leurs représentants et avec
les forces de l'ordre dans leur
quotidien ce sont des gens qui ont fait
beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires
pourquoi ils ont fait beaucoup d'heures
supplémentaires parce qu'on a réduit ses
effectifs entre 2007 et 2012 a annoncé
les spécialistes de la sécurité qui
réduisent les effectifs et bien du coup
il ya eu encore plus d'heures
supplémentaires de réaliser et ils sont
dans une situation où pour eux la seule
façon de pouvoir entre guillemets
bénéficie d'un retour de ses heures
supplémentaires c'est de les prendre à
récupérer ce qui est très compliqué
puisqu'il y a nécessité de présence
forte sur le terrain eh bien nous avons
engagé avec christophe castaner avec
gérald darmanin nous avons engagé le
paiement de ses heures supplémentaires
voilà les annonces du président d'un but
je lui laisserai les faire tout à
l'heure mais vous savez je lise exemple
que je vous donne montre l'engagement du
gouvernement sur ce sujet de la sécurité
on va parler de la crise sanitaire
cristal oui alors le pass sanitaire est
entrée en vigueur depuis quelques temps
j'aimerais savoir déjà quel bilan vous
en fait de l' usage de ce pass
sanitaires
écoutez d'abord je regarde ce qui se
passe à l'étranger je regarde comment le
ps sanitaire français a été pris comme
exemple pour nos nombreux pays européens
et ça c'est un bon indicateur pouces est
parfois dans notre pays on a du mal à se
réjouir de ce qu'on a réussi et bien
collectivement collectivement nous avons
réussi en mettant en place passani terre
à préserver le lien social à préserver
les activités qui nous font plaisir de
loisir d'aller au cinéma au restaurant
nous avons affronté vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure nous avons affronté une
quatrième vague avec des taux
d'incidence qui était supérieur à ce que
nous avons pour connu lors du
confinement et nous avons réussi à le
faire en maintenant les activités de
loisirs ouverte grâce au pass interview
c'est une réussite a inspiré départ il
repère mais l'angleterre est en train
d'y renoncer aujourd'hui à 100 écoutez
la politique outre-manche
en matière sanitaire elle appartient au
gouvernement de l'autre côté du channel
moi je vais lui laisser ses choix en la
matière ce que je constate c'est que ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui à la fois
de dire pour les 1 million 800 mille
salariés qui sont concernés par le
passage du ter lorsqu'on demande à ceux
qui viennent dans votre environnement de
travail des clients notamment d'avoir le
pas salutaire il est logique et cohérent
que vous l'ayez vous même pour créer
cette bulle de protection lorsque l'
étendue à d'autres catégories de
salariés moi c'est pas prévu aujourd'hui
c'est pas prévu aujourd'hui et en vérité
nous voyons bien que ça fonctionne voilà
si chaque étape que nous mettons en
place de cette protection collective et
individuelle réussi eh bien nous ne
sommes pas obligés d'aller plus loin
d'étendre les mesures eh bien on sait ce
qu'on préférerait tous à vous et moi
c'est de ne pas avoir de passe à une
terre moi je ne suis pas un obsédé du
passani terre moi je suis un obsédé de
la sécurité de nos concitoyens je suis
je suis volontaire et je veux que nous
réussissions collectivement à la fois
nous protéger collectivement et
individuellement ça s'arrêtera quand le
passé à lithaire c'est comme la réforme
des retraites le moment venu non mais
j'ai encore une fois c'est l'analogie
que vous faites est pas totalement
inintéressante parce que en fait vous
faites vous même le lien et oui vous
pouviez pas me reprocher de le faire
tout à l'heure entre la situation
sanitaire est le moment de déclencher de
grandes réformes structurelles écoutez
quand la situation sanitaire le
permettra évidemment mettront un terme à
ces dispositifs et je vous dire on
le voit bien ensemble
avançons dans la vaccination dépassons
les 50 millions de français vaccinés et
doux pour ranger se passe sanitaire
parce que nous serons tous at in et les
manifestations contre le passé ni terre
ne cesse pas depuis cet été est ce que
ça vous inquiète est-ce que quelques
mois d'une élection présidentielle ça ne
peut pas cristalliser une forme
d'opposition qui pourraient être
dangereuses pour la majorité en place
moi je pense qu'il faut rester vigilant
toujours à l'expression
collectif de citoyens donc il ya des
citoyens qui sont inquiets d'ailleurs je
trouve je vais pas si vous l'avez vu je
pense que vous l'avez mais je trouve que
le petit clip qui présente une
discussion en famille il a autour d'un
barbecue sur le sujet dieu axa où on
voit des gens qui discutent entre eux et
au final on liban peut discuter de tout
mais pas de la vérité des chiffres eh
bien je pense que c'est une bonne
représentation de notre société il ya
des questions qui peuvent se poser il
faut y répondre il faut entendre les
questions il faut y répondre j'essaye de
le faire aujourd'hui avec vous nous
avons des milliards de francs de france
eh oui pas que d'autres français le
citoyen et le monde 1 qui sont vaccinées
aujourd'hui et nous voyons bien l'impact
que cela a au total
c'est une succès cette stratégie
vaccinale donc il faut entendre l
afrique et les altitudes permettent les
changes et moi je crois très franchement
que d'ailleurs c'est les chiffres qui le
disent il y avait peut-être un peu moins
de monde n'y sont inquiets et que nous
avons sont dans cette confiance qui est
nécessaire envers la stratégie
occidentale
oui lors des journées parlementaires de
la république en marche et du modem
de nombreuses questions se sont posées
autour de la structuration d'une maison
commune à toute la majorité
présidentielle
j'avais envie de savoir si vous y êtes
favorable et comment vous imaginez cette
maison commune qui peut être regroupés
oui oui je suis très favorable à un
grand mouvement présidentiel un grand
mouvement réformateur démocrate où je
crois mais
j'en suis à la fois à l'adhérent est un
membre actif du bureau exécutif moi je
ne crois pas que il faille dissoudre les
uns et les autres dans une pensée
commune moyenne usante moi je crois
beaucoup à l' enthousiasme du collectif
je crois à la force des idées qui aussi
émergent parce que on se confronte avec
certains qui tout en ayant les mêmes
aspirations de réformes sociales que
vous envie de faire réussir l'intérêt
général moi je crois à cela inclut qui
dans cette grande maison écoutez moi je
crois que tous ceux qui ont vocation à
soutenir l'action du président de la
république je pense que c'est ce doit
être cela l'ambition d'un grand
mouvement aux démocrates et réformateurs
qui sera candidat pour un nouveau mandat
ça semble faire peu de doute est-ce que
vous travaillez déjà à mettre la réforme
des retraites dans son programme et
quelles réformes bah écoutez moi je
travaille au quotidien à protéger la
santé des salariés c'est le mandat tu
m'as donné le président la république
sous l'autorité du premier ministre et à
traiter tous les mois car faut pas
oublier qu'on a plus de 17 millions de
retraités dans le pays moi tous les mois
je vérifie qu'ils perçoivent leurs
pensions tous les ans
je m'attelle à ce que les près de 700000
demande de retraite se voit obtenir une
réponse bien là les formes il faudra
présenter dans cette campagne est ce que
c'est la réforme par points qui avait
été présenté lors de la précédente
campagne où est ce que là il faut
s'attaquer à l équilibre du régime et ce
sera forcément une réforme paramétrique
avec un report de l'âge de départ moi je
crois à l'universalité on ne peut pas se
dire que lorsqu'on a une infirmière dans
un secteur d'activité à l'est un niveau
de retraite qui soit différente d'une
même infirmière qui serait dans un autre
secteur d'activité et je crois que tout
cela doit se poser doit se poser dans un
échange de fond nous en avons mené un
longue le mans vous savez que cette
réforme a été arrêté par la crise
sanitaire le président de la république
l'a dit lui même nous ne répondrons pas
la réforme là où il a été arrêté il
faudra que nous réclamions des
concertations
pardon nouveaux débats durant la
campagne écoutez je pense que de toute
façon ce sujet va nous occuper pendant
les semaines qui viennent ou même avant
la campagne et vous viendrez nous en
parler avec catherine date pour savoir
comment les mesures seront prises merci
beaucoup laurent piètre hs qui
d'ailleurs était notre invité ce matin
en regardant une de la dépêche du midi
vaccins les soignants au pied du mur
c'est à la une de votre journal
aujourd'hui christelle merci beaucoup
[Musique]